you know i wanted to talk about a really
good remedy if you have vein problems in
your legs
but the first thing i want to talk about
is what actually is
the venous system and how does it differ
from the arterial system well veins
carry blood
from your legs and your fingertips back
to the heart so they're carrying the
blood that is deoxygenated
without oxygen and what's unique about
veins is it doesn't really have a
pumping system
it only pumps with motion or movement of
muscles
so if you're sedentary if you stand a
lot
then you may have more vein problems but
we have all these different arteries
that go all the way down to
your feet and your fingertips
and then they go into tiny little
capillaries and then the oxygen and
nutrition is released into the tissues
then it comes back up to the heart
through the venous system but you also
have a venous system that's connected
with your digestion which carries the
nutrients from your digestive system
back up through the liver
and then back to the heart that's called
the hepatic
portal system
and if there's any obstruction
in your liver
as in scar tissue
cirrhosis
or a fatty liver there's going to be a
problem with your veins okay like a
backup of pressure into the venous
system you can pretty much think about
the liver like a sponge right so if the
sponge is
filled with
something that's obstructing
the flow of fluid through it whether
it's some scar tissue or fat
then the sponge can't work it's not
going to be able to hold the fluids it's
not going to be able to function
correctly and it's definitely going to
create a backup of pressure if this
sponge is connected to
some plumbing just like if you had your
water filter completely plugged up with
a bunch of you know dirt and things it's
going to back up pressure so in certain
parts of your house you're going to have
a lack of flow and other parts you're
going to have increased flow and when
there's too much pressure in the venous
system it can create things like
varicose veins it can back up veins also
in your esophagus that's called
esophageal varices or veins in the lower
rectum which is called
hemorrhoids or it can affect these veins
in your stomach called gastric varices
so one big cause of vein problems is the
liver but today i want to primarily
focus on something called chronic venous
insufficiency where you're getting a
problem mostly in the lower part of your
legs where the vein circulation is not
moving one term for this is chronic
venous insufficiency which then causes
varicose veins and spider veins and
phlebitis which is inflammation in your
veins or even potentially something
called deep vein thrombosis where you're
getting clots in your veins some of the
symptoms that are related to a lack of
flow in the venous system is number one
heavy legs number two swelling in the
legs and ankle
pain in the legs restlessness in the
legs
uh the skin is going to be affected so
the skin might look shiny or it might
give a leathery uh appearance you may
lose your hair in your legs it might be
itchy or you might have a color change
in the lower legs now a lot of
women after pregnancy start to develop
varicose veins and vein problems in
their lower legs and this is related to
estrogen so estrogen is another
cause of venous problems apparently
there's just not a lot of studies on
this but we do know there's receptors
for estrogen in your veins and so if you
have too much estrogen that can affect
the vascular system and this also
happens in men too and what happens with
women when they get through menopause
their estrogen goes down but their
progesterone really goes down and so
this gives an kind of an appearance of a
high estrogen to low progesterone ratio
so even though they have low estrogen
they have extremely low progesterone so
this could be considered as an estrogen
dominant situation now in men as they
age the testosterone does go down
and that's going to give them higher
amounts of relative estrogen too and
especially if their liver is damaged
because the liver is a key organ to
regulate or buffer this estrogen so that
being said the number one best remedy
for vein problems in your lower legs
is this red vine leaf extract and i
found this data
in a patent where they had all this
additional research and of course this
patent was probably based on the huge
study they did it was a randomized
placebo controlled
double-blinded clinical trial on quite a
few people who had mild to moderate
venous insufficiency now the amount of
red vine leaf extract that they used was
between 360 to 720 milligrams per day
for 12 weeks and the results were
significant red vine leaf is also good
for enlarged liver
and a large spleen
swelling in your legs hemorrhoids
bruising bleeding
nasal congestion capillary thickness and
it's a great anti-inflammatory and it
also helps to balance the permeability
within your capillaries the other thing
i would recommend is to start doing the
rebound exercise simply because that's
going to start increasing lymph flow and
help push some of this fluid through
your veins and of course i would
definitely recommend doing walking on a
regular basis you want to keep active
you do not want to do a lot of sitting
you don't want to do a lot of standing
now if there is a liver problem which
is very common in these cases
the remedy that i would recommend is
called tut cup
it's a type of bile salt that is not
only good for a fatty liver but it's
also good for cirrhosis of the liver and
tutka will actually increase the flow of
bile through the bile ducts now
if there's an estrogen problem if there
is an estrogen dominant problem i would
recommend a product called dim which is
a super concentrated
anti-estrogenic
cruciferous blend now since we're on the
topic of estrogen in the liver if you
haven't seen this video i think this
would be a really good one for you to
watch next check it out